out I mean if it were kind of a natural  situation where it was a normal game  where both sides played Fighting Chess I  think we would have seen a draw but  because Eric icy had such a dominating  position  he's not ready to let go of that Victory  maybe it's good strategy for the match  in general for Eric I see he's the  younger player  um also he's getting it out of his  system the longer he plays this one the  more he'll forget that he was completely  winning earlier in the game  how about you Ivanka have you had this  end game before once I was on the  defending side and you I drew I I was  just and this is also finally you draw  both players shaking their heads look at  Eric I see he obviously knows he was  completely winning this game  but now it is a draw the first game and  in 15 minutes Magnus Carlsen will have  the white pieces in game two in their  quarterfinals it was a long and  interesting game and here is today's  Lisa vetta learning point